[Musique]
je m'appelle franck romero je suis le
fondateur et ceo de bandes axe c'est une
marque qui fabrique des bandages pour la
protection des mains des combattants
multidisciplines nous sommes basés sur
plaisir dans les yvelines depuis 2017
[Musique]
macrez justement un produit pour
protéger les mains des boxeurs s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait un problème à
ce niveau-là notamment à l'entraînement
on a à coeur de toujours protéger les
boxeurs du mieux possible pour qu'ils
puissent performer et être au top de
leur forme
[Musique]
j'ai commencé avec trois rouleaux
demandé 600 euros en poche je
travaillais à côté donc c'était je
travaillais la journée le soir j'allais
à la salve entraîné entraîné les petits
aussi puisqu'à l'époque j'ai passé mon
diplôme de coach et le soir je
fabriquais les pères pour pour les
clients tout s'est fait sur fonds
propres en fait gérés injecter chaque
vente m'a permis de faire améliorer le
produit
on a eu à coeur de créer et de
développer un concept est un produit
unique au monde qui permettait d'avoir
un bandage professionnels mais surtout
réutilisables dans le temps le chiffre
d'affaires a doublé ces dernières années
donc on est très contents actuellement
on est consulté pour plusieurs milliers
de paires nous avons exporté des
bandages dans 35 pays sur les 5
continents notamment dans des pays comme
les etats-unis la chine la russie le
japon le brésil
[Musique]
c'est aussi ça le rôle d'une start-up
ces deux aussi pouvoir être évolutif et
de pas être figé aujourd'hui si on doit
investir dans une machine trouver une
nouvelle un nouveau composant une
nouvelle méthode
on va forcément la mettre en place pour
proposer le meilleur aux boxeurs et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est de
toujours pouvoir proposer le meilleur
[Musique]